Coffman here um one of the people who
follows my blog name is Stefan has asked
me to do a video about language learning
and age now first of all let me say that
this morning I played the old-timers
hockey most the guys are 65 68 70 some
of those 60s early 60s um I tell you
when I'm out there playing hockey I
think I'm ten fifteen it's the same
feeling except that we after the game
were allowed to go and have a beer so I
must have been over the legal drinking
age we're having just as much fun the
same kind of conversation we're trying
just as hard in the game fighting for
the puck trying to make passes set
people up this kind of thing probably
less inclined to get into shoving
matches and that kind of stuff a little
bit less aggressive um so when I went
there I think I'm 15 or 20 um you know I
hate it when I go somewhere and people
ask me if I want the seniors discount
because I I thought it was maybe you
know a lot younger than that how do you
know that I'm 66 Wow um to me age is
largely in your mind if you want to
learn a language
I don't think age has much to do with it
I mean from the research and so forth
it appears that very young children are
able to learn very quickly because my
understanding of it is that the brain
has not yet sort of crystallized that
the brain is kind of this Darwinian
space where different different things
are competing for for room and so if you
have a lot of exposure to language a
that will tend to become dominant if you
have a lot of exposure to several
languages you may be more flexible I
think yeah children under the age of 10
or 12 are less inhibited they're into
communicating or not
worrying about how they sound this kind
of thing so they they tend to do better
adults can often learn more quickly than
children to the extent that I'll have a
much larger vocabulary in their own
language and so therefore they have more
reference points I'm sure that you know
seniors of my age that their memory and
and and some of their you know euro
skills have declined just like their
body is not as strong but I don't have
the impression personally that it
impacts on my ability to learn languages
I don't think language learning is so
much a matter of memory as I've said
before I think is although memory
certainly plays a part I think it's more
a matter of noticing you know if I'm
listening to check I have to notice how
it's pronounced I have to notice where
you know the emphasis is in a word I
have to notice certain structures I try
to make them natural I try to remember
certain things but I can't remember what
I can't notice and so I think noticing
is is the big thing and I think noticing
it depends on a number of factors it
depends on our state of mind are we
interested do we think we can do it are
we alert are we you know keen we're more
likely to notice if we are I'm an
experienced language learner so I will
notice certain things if there are
certain things in check that are similar
to Russian I will notice them you know
if you know some tense things that I
mean I noticed for example the
similarity in all European languages in
terms of the structure of the verbs
these are things that I notice because I
have learned so many languages I think
you notice if you expose yourself to a
lot of the language through repetitive
listening and eventually not so
repetitive and reading and and so more
and more things become clearer so that
you're able to notice these other things
that you can't notice at first I don't
think any of these things relate
so much to age I mean I would be quite
willing to - now I'm not a good example
because I'm an experienced language
learner I've learned a lot of languages
but I don't feel I feel that I'm a
better language learner today than I was
when I was in high school because I
wasn't very interested in high school
and I had not had the experience of
converting myself into a relatively
fluent speaker of another language so I
didn't have the confidence I didn't have
I didn't know how to go about it um I
haven't noticed that it my age that I
forget things more quickly
you know and my Czech I've been added
for six months I'm I'm still pinching
myself that you know I had my I won't
look for it now but I had my
conversation with yarda and he sent me
his his comments at the bottom there
were 10 lines of common there wasn't a
single word there that I didn't know now
obviously when I import text about Czech
history or the story of the life of
Bedrich Smetana then there are more
words that I don't know but I can still
pick my way through those things and
I've been at it now you know six months
an hour and a half a day kind of thing I
don't notice that I'm slowing down so I
mean if we look at the different stages
okay the infant for sure is going to
learn to pronounce like a native because
that's what they that's there is nothing
else interfering with that they will you
know even as children younger children
under the age of ten twelve there does
communicate naturally without any hint
of innovations without feeling
self-conscious and to that extent they
will more naturally learn the language
but once you pass the age of 1215 I
haven't noticed any difference I guess
if I remember when I was at language
school studying Chinese which was the
only time I actually went to a language
school I mean the assumption and there
you had you know people sent there by
their employer by the government or
which their employer to learn a language
and the assumption will always was that
the older guy would have more trouble
and at that you know in those days I was
22
so to me a 45 year old was an old guy
and they did have more trouble
pod to me today a 45 year old is a young
guy and I can't see why they would have
trouble and I look at my son mark
who has become somewhat belatedly
interested in languages he wasn't that
interested when we I was trying to force
him to learn French as a child but he
learns very well he's you know I would
have thought him old when I was studying
Chinese I think a part of it is the way
I think a lot of the people who are past
20 they think they're not going to be
able to do it
they are inhibited they're easily
embarrassed they don't focus on noticing
the language because it too much
concerned about themselves and worrying
about themselves and can I do it and how
do I sound and and yeah I think I think
if you approach language learning as
some kind of a memory task where you're
going to have to remember a bunch of
rules and a bunch of vocabulary you can
quickly persuade yourself that you can't
do it if you approach language learning
is something that you're going to
basically immerse yourself in through a
lot of listening and reading or if
you're lucky enough to live in the
country where the language is spoken you
can get exposure and if you feel that
you're just going to be able to learn it
and if you take the initiative of
regularly consulting a grammar book and
and here again you talk about noticing
when I start noticing certain structures
and I wonder why then I'm quite keen to
go to the grammar book and look it up
and see some of the rules and the
patterns and and there it has a chance
of sticking whereas if it's kind of
forced on me according to some
curriculum today we're going to study
the subjunctive and I say like I don't
even know what the subjunctive is I
haven't even noticed it yet then it's
not gonna stick but if I start noticing
it and why does the verb change there
then I'm ripe and ready to to learn that
so to me the big thing is believing in
yourself liking the task liking what
you're doing enjoying it like I mean I
go out and it does it matter if as an
older person you learn less quickly then
as a younger person I'm not sure you do
but even if you do you know does it
matter to us a bunch of 60
60-plus people out there playing hockey
having just a tremendous time it doesn't
matter that in fact we are much slower
than we think we are slower than we used
to be or maybe we were never that fast
in the first place uh I don't think it
matters so the quick answer is I am not
convinced that age is a big deal beyond
childhood and if it is it's an a
relatively minor issue and what is much
more important as your attitude are you
focused are you paying attention are you
exposing yourself enough to enough of
the language are you enjoying the
language are you enjoying the process
and if the answer to all of that is yes
then the question of your age really
doesn't matter thank you for listening
and I look forward to your comments